إحدى الطرق التي يقوم بها بعض الأطباء بتقييم
المرضى خلال هذا
التصوير بالموجات فوق الصوتية الوبائية لرئتيهم ، لكن
عمليات الفحص التقليدية يمكن أن تستغرق وقتًا
وموارد كثيفة ، تقوم
العديد من الشركات بتطوير
الأجهزة التي تضع تقنية الموجات فوق الصوتية
في راحة أيدي العاملين في مجال الرعاية الصحية ،
وتسمى إحدى هذه الشركات
الفراشة ،
إنها  تسمح الموجات فوق الصوتية المحمولة التي تسمى
Butterfly iq
لممارسي الرعاية الصحية
بإدارة
الموجات فوق الصوتية بشكل أسرع وأكثر كفاءة أينما
كانوا يرون المرضى
نوعًا من الأشياء ستكون
أجهزة الفحص
وليس جهاز التشخيص ،
قد لا تكون جودة الصورة رائعة ولكن
الجودة الرئيسية موجودة و  إذا كنت سأقوم
بنقطة رعاية بالموجات فوق الصوتية
على جانب سرير المريض ،
فسأعطيني تقريبًا كل ما أحتاجه
من شركات أخرى مثل ge و philips
أيضًا طورت أجهزة مماثلة
العديد منها يتصل بهاتف ذكي أو
جهاز لوحي ويعرض  التصوير في
الوقت
الحقيقي للمرضى المصابين بـ covid19 هذا
تسمح التكنولوجيا للطبيب بالتقييم السريع
لصحة رئتيه
والمخاطر المحتملة للمضاعفات القاتلة
المتعلقة بفيروس
الفراشة ، حيث يقول أحدهم إن تقنيتها
يمكن أيضًا أن تقلل بشكل كبير من خطر انتقال
التلوث
والوقت الذي يقضيه في التطهير بين
المرضى وهو أمر مهم بشكل خاص
أثناء الوباء
حقيقة أنه يمكنني إحضار
نظام الموجات فوق الصوتية المحمول
الذي يتم توصيله بهاتف في غرفة
ما ، أحتاج إلى الحصول على المعلومات التي
أحتاجها للخروج وتطهير الهاتف
ومسبار مقارنة بالدفع في عربة بها
ثلاثة مجسات مختلفة
هذا الاختبار نفسه ليلًا ونهارًا حقًا
من حيث سهولة التطهير ، فإن
إجراء الموجات فوق الصوتية
بجانب سرير المريض المصاب بدلاً من
أخذهم إلى جهاز الأشعة السينية أو جهاز التصوير المقطعي
يعني أيضًا أن عددًا أقل من
الأشخاص يتعاملون معهم
إذا كنت أنا كعلاج طارئ
يمكن للطبيب أن يمشي في الغرفة
بكامل معدات الوقاية
الشخصية والتحدث إلى المريض وفحصها
وكل منها  من التصوير في نفس
الوقت ،
لست بحاجة إلى نقل هذا المريض
إلى منطقة أخرى من المستشفى للحصول على
مزيد من التصوير والتعرض
لموظفين إضافيين وربما
مرضى على طول الطريق
بحيث تكون قابلية النقل ذات قيمة كبيرة
بالنسبة لنا
حاليًا لأجهزة ge phillips and butterflyflies
يتراوح السعر من ألفي
دولار
إلى ما يزيد عن خمسة آلاف دولار ،
فنحن لا نحاول مقارنة Butterfly
iq
بنظام الموجات فوق الصوتية 200000 ، لذلك هناك بالتأكيد
بعض التطبيقات التي قد ترغب في خوضها
لإجراء اختبار شامل
لدينا نقطة رعاية
لدراسة الموجات فوق الصوتية حتى الموجات فوق الصوتية الطويلة
الطويلة خارج covid ،
هناك الكثير من التطبيقات وكنا نستخدم
التصوير فوق الصوتي للرئة لفحص
المرضى الذين يعانون من ضيق في التنفس
وألم في الصدر قبل وقت طويل من الرغبة في
ذلك وسنستخدمه من أجل  انظر إليهم بعد فترة طويلة
من التعامل مع cobit